you talked previously about lack of
confidence how much would you
mentally beat yourself up over things
well
honestly when writing that first book i
don't think i beat myself up about it
too much because i didn't
really have a plan of what i was going
to do with it you know i just wanted to
do it
um so in that sense
i think it was easier because i just it
was more about getting it done
to you know it's writing a novel at that
time to me
seemed like such a insurmountable
challenge i mean it really
seemed like climbing a mountain or
something crazy you know i was like so
even if i could just do it i would have
been happy you know like that was
all that was all i was really sort of
thinking about at that time
um i'd say the confidence more comes
from uh like in screenplays and tv
writing things where you really need to
put yourself out there you know i mean i
worked
that that writing job that i talked
about that i got really came about
because
finally after many years and many
opportunities where i could have put
myself out there
i just started yeah i don't maybe it was
just the right environment it was a very
creative kind of young company and
everyone was super friendly and chill
maybe i hadn't had the right environment
yet but i just started to say like hey
you know the development executive would
uh i remember one time he was uh like
kind of pulling out his hair and i was
like oh what's wrong he's like i forgot
you know we have to shoot this
sizzle tomorrow and i need a script and
i didn't i didn't write it and now i'm
screwed and i was like i'll write it for
you and
he's like can you do that i was like
well sure you know and i was like i
figured
how bad could it be you know like they
needed something and they didn't have it
so i figured anything's better than that
you know so i uh
i wrote it up and he took it home and
then he called me actually from the road
and said hey i faxed it
i sent your script to the boss and you
know he loved it and he said who wrote
it and i said andrew did
and he was like really surprised you
know so from that point on i started
writing all of their you know their
sizzle reels on all their pitches and
uh i they actually optioned several
shows from me you know they didn't get
made but they
they you know that was sort of where i
started realizing that
you know it doesn't there's no harm in
putting yourself out there you know i
just
you know once i got a little positive
feedback it was easier you know but i
should have been doing that
years ago you know i mean always if you
have ideas
share them you know put them out there
even even if people say no
it can't hurt you know you're going to
hear a lot of no's in this business you
might as well get used to it but you
never know
so do you think it's having confidence
or the rejections don't sting as much
and so then you're like oh well oh well
probably a little of both i mean
certainly i think as you get older it
just
starts to get easier because you just
inevitably accumulate more rejections
you know i mean it's like dating you
know like when you're
in high school it's the end of the world
if the girl you like won't go to dance
with you but when you're
40 like it's just another you know okay
on to the next one you know
um so i i don't know what i don't know
what the
i don't know the answer is but i think
it's really important not to let
rejection
discourage you i mean i just think
that's what it all comes down to
you're going to face rejection
finding your own way to to face that
and overcome it and just keep going and
keep trying things i think
is really what's going to separate you
know the winners from the losers
can we go back to when you first came to
la and
talk about confidence when you maybe got
off the plane or i don't know if he
drove out here well i think when i when
i came out to la
i was super confident because we had
this movie and like we thought it was
going to be great and we thought we were
going to be you know like the next
i don't know like clerks or whatever was
the big indie thing at that time
and it didn't go that route but even
even so like we were already on to the
sort of the next thing you know
so i i i don't i think really what it
was was
i think you it's super important in
anything whether it's
writing novels screenplays relationships
anything i i always call
it or i say you need to be careful you
don't give in to
lottery thinking you know it's like that
idea that
this one thing is it you know and if
this one thing
doesn't work out you're screwed that's
it you know it's over or if it does work
out that it's going to make you
suddenly you're rich and on easy street
in my experience
uh that's just not you know the way it
were i mean sure
maybe it works like that for a very
small percentage of people like that's
why i call lottery thinking but those
are the people you tend to hear about
but even if you look at really
successful people that
you know write a screenplay that that
you know does really well and launches
their career or that sell their first
novel
even even me and i'm not saying i'm
super successful at all but like even my
first novel it's not
really you know i'd written four or five
half novels and
dozens of short stories you don't see
all the work
that's kind of hiding in the shadows you
know you just see that one thing and so
you think if i could just get this one
thing i'll
have it made and so i think that one i
kind of gave into that with that one
script you know that i thought would get
made
you know there's no reason why i
couldn't have kept shopping that script
around
or why wasn't i working on another
script you know to follow that up
i mean that went on for you know
probably that whole option period was
probably about two years
um you know i certainly could have
written other things but i just got very
tunnel vision focused you know on that
one thing happening and when it didn't
happen
that just kind of like i said took the
wind out of my sails and i just kind of
gave up for a while after that and that
was
in my opinion a big mistake you know on
my part
but you didn't go quote unquote back
home
no because at that point i was pretty
established here in terms of
working i had you know i had a job and i
had a girlfriend and a life and
so i didn't go back home and i still i
don't think i consciously
gave up like i still thought in my head
oh i'll work on this and i still had
ideas and stuff but
i can in terms of the amount of work i
put into it the amount of effort i put
into it i can see i really kind of just
let it slide from that point i sort of
stopped
putting myself out there you know and
that was a mistake
do you think that the fact that you
finished um
the first novel that that gave you
confidence that certainly gave me
confidence
i think i mean there was a lot of things
i mean i finished the first novel
um and then i s a friend of mine she was
a uh
english major she was one of my very
good friend's wife she had been an
english major she had done some
freelance editing and she knew i was
working on it
and she said as a birthday gift i'll do
i'll edit it for free for you as an edit
so i had done one edit like where i just
sent it off to a service
but i knew it still needed a little more
work so i was like okay great like it'll
have like two edits and that'll get it
into shape
and she read it and she
you know she also had a very favorable
reaction she was like this is really
good like you know i
got to the end and i was just like
turning pages to see what happened and
so
you know she's still a friend still not
a completely unbiased opinion but
it was like a little bit more unbiased
than my girlfriend you know so each step
of the way i'm like okay people seem to
like this you know
maybe maybe it's not bad you know um
and then really you know i ended up
self-publishing it
through amazon and i did that because
i already had some projects optioned at
that point the the tv shows i had
mentioned and i had kind of gone through
that
process a few times you know where
you're really you're
you're sort of dependent on someone else
you know in essence
unfortunately and i just didn't want to
do it again you know i mean
i knew i would have to for other feature
you know screenplays and things like
that so i said maybe i'll just do this
for me and i'll just put it out
and i was fine you know if no one buys
it or if it doesn't do well that's fine
it's out there i wrote it
i put it out there that was really all i
wanted from it you know
um and i put it out and it did well like
not
amazing i certainly couldn't quit
working off of it at the time but it did
well and
more importantly the reviews were really
good and they were
even more important than being really
good like i said they were exactly what
i
had hoped you know i mean i put it out
there saying i want this to be
like a mental vacation for someone i
want people to feel like they've gone to
japan i want them to like kind of get an
experience outside their normal life
and i want them to feel like they saw
like this really awesome
action movie and that's what the reviews
were like i mean the
pretty much all of my reviews for all of
my books
the two things that come up more than
anything else are you know i really
feel like i was there and it feels very
cinematic
and i'm sure that comes from the fact
that i had much more experience at that
point with screenplays than i did with
novels and i guess that translated
but so when i started getting those
reviews i'd say that
probably was the biggest confidence
builder because these are people who
not only don't know me they spent money
and bought it and they liked it
so i i think once i saw that i was like
okay like i have something here and i
need to start
you know pursuing this did you promote
the book at all once you had it on
amazon i did
um you know there's a whole sort of
once i decided i was going to
self-publish it i did do quite a bit of
research into how that works and there's
a lot of information out there there are
a lot of other self-published authors
and so i didn't just go into it blind
and i actually do consulting with other
authors to sort of help them because you
really do need
a plan you know i mean there are i think
when i launched it there were probably
like 5 million books
in the amazon store now i think there's
10 million you know so if you just
you know squirt it out there and don't
do anything it's you're probably not
you know gonna get it you know if you're
if your goal is just to publish a book
and say it's out there that's fine i
mean i think that's a worthy goal for
many people
but if you want to uh make money off of
it you absolutely have to have sort of a
marketing plan
so um what i did was while that
uh editor while that second editor was
working on it i wrote a
novella that was uh prequel and so i
started giving away the novella for free
to uh build up a list of reader and
email list of readers and then when
the other book was ready then i could
email all those readers and say okay now
the sequel is available you know that
was sort of how i
started it so sorry so tokyo black was
the novel but then you were preparing it
and then you wrote the novella and gave
it away for free yeah
how interesting okay so while the
because it went through those two rounds
of editing the
the novel uh in the second round the the
very kind
woman who did it for free for me you
know it took her a while like you know
because she was working a job at the
same time
so while she was doing that i'd say that
probably took two or three months like
for her to finish
um so while she did that i i wrote the
the novella which i had you know
directly designed as a sort of prequel
that would lead into it
so how many words is a novella uh that
one was about 20 000.
and then the novel was about 85 000.
interesting okay
and so you gave that away for free and
then
so you had your website because you have
a beautiful website by the way because
you have these cool maps
that you have one map that i looked at
where it it has like the different books
and
it shows which country it corresponds to
and you know
beautiful friend of mine he's also an
author his name is aiden he made that
map he lives in
australia and i've worked with him on a
few projects and he
put that together i could never do that
oh okay but he made it for me but yeah
um
yeah exactly so i would give it away
through my website i also
you know when you're an independent
publisher you're real or when you're an
independent author you are really a
publisher
as well and so i had to learn quite a
bit about um
advertising marketing um
and i started to dip my toe in all of
that and i ran
facebook ads um you know i did uh
swaps with other authors in the genre
where they would they would
give away my book to their readers and i
would give away their book and we would
share
you know interested readers email
addresses and things like that there's
there's a you know if you once you start
researching none of these things are
super uh
like groundbreaking or hard to find like
if you're once you decide you want to go
down that path there's a lot of
resources out there
there's groups on facebook there's books
about how to do it and you know these
are all sort of the
standard tactics you'll hear people talk
about
how did you know who your audience was
when you first started
i don't think i did i mean i mean other
than that i mean look
i think uh you know definitely they
there's a big thing in in writing books
about finding your ideal reader
and i think that's true to some degree
but i also think people
go a little overboard with it because i
mean i'm not
if i'm writing spy fiction that's a
pretty
well tread genre you know i mean if you
like spy fiction you know you like spy
fiction you know or if you like science
fiction you know you like science
fiction
so i never really worried too much about
trying to pinpoint
uh you know is my ideal reader a 40 year
old you know middle manager with you
know
two dogs and whatever some people do
and if that works for them great but i
just i just thought of it i just tried
to write a book i would like
honestly that was really what it came
down to
you